allô oui à longwy à bonjour monsieur
voilà je téléphone parce que je voudrais
parler à monsieur quand huit au oui non
oui c'est à dire que oui en pcv oui si
oui oui oui pardon oui oui ne quittais
d'accord monsieur ne quittez pas ne
quittez pas allô oui vous êtes là oui
oui moi je voudrais parler
akkaoui tôt oui oui on peut lui paye le
pc oui oui je oui bien sûr oui d'accord
oui ne quittait pas d'accord monsieur ne
quittez pas allô oui non c'est moi qui
appelle depuis tous les cp puis ce que
vous faisiez vous avez entendu la
sonnerie ces manques à peine oui oui oui
oui vraiment je weeds d'accord monsieur
ne quittez pas d'accord
allô allô vous êtes oui oui ah ah non je
regrette je ne peux pas parlé plus haut
oui pourquoi voulez vous je raccroche
pourquoi je vais raccrocher pour
pénélope
mais qu'est ce vous parlez de
l'antiquité et penelope viser un là en
la comédie musicale de dany saval et ses
esprits c'est bien l'équipe la clé là
pour chanter mais je le sais monsieur je
commence aussi eu le cran je suis sur
place
alors